Demba shoka and Carson and see Allah are
marching on the streets of Township
soweto near Johannesburg their members
of the main opposition party da
democratic alliance they are going
door-to-door to convince people there's
an urgent need for change in South
Africa this is a plan Zuma take ova it's
a mess look at the current economy you
will see that a South Africa's in
disaster South Africa's on a brink of a
recession the black youth is the hardest
hit forty percent is unemployed to blame
they say is their president people are
sick and tired of zuma zuma must fall
these are slogans that are hurting more
and more in South Africa mainly about
the urban young generation resentment
has been brewing again Zuma who's been
involved in corruption scandals and
recently fired a capable finance
minister after which the South African
currency went into a freefall welcome
today I'm not happy in prison to present
Zoma he promises houses he promised
electricity's you promised plenty of
things but those things they don't
happen although more and more people
agree zoom as an a good president this
doesn't mean they see the DA is the
solution the party has not been able to
get even close to the ANC we have 8.4
million be honest what African those who
are not Wiggy they're going to make them
work it is a great job for have with us
Roy white it's a white part is a purple
for a white party not for me since last
year the DA is a black leader but it's
still seen as a white party well the ANC
still has massive support because it
liberated a country from apartheid grew
up alone in see that's why I'm Stevie
to you Zuma can remain an office as long
as the E and C Backson